trailer Matt wall show Media Matters
exposes my sordid past as an obscure
shock jock morning radio host they
believe that this will be the thing that
finally brings me down but spoiler alert
that's not going to happen also Vox
admits that kids are being transitioned
but argues that we have to do it for
their own sake Joe Biden declares that
the debate over climate change is over
because of Hurricane Ian and a mother
shows up to a school board meeting
dressed like a drag queen but she's
trying to make a point and doing it
rather brilliantly I think talk about
all that and much more today for the
Matt Walsh show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
price index increasing yet again the
stock market has been an absolute
turmoil what is the current
Administration doing to quell The Surge
of inflation while spending more
taxpayer dollars don't bear your head in
the sand while your savings deplete
diversify into gold with Birch gold
today text Walsh to 989898 and Birch
gold will send you a free info kit on
protecting your savings with gold in a
tax sheltered account the experts over
at Birch gold have almost 20 years of
experience in converting IRAs and 401ks
into precious metal IRAs with an A plus
rating and the Better Business Bureau
countless five-star reviews and
thousands of satisfied customers why
haven't you checked them out yet for
yourself gold has always been your best
hedge against inflation a diversified
savings can protect you from downturns
in the market text Walsh to 98 98 98 and
Birch gold will send you a free info kit
on diversifying into gold tax free take
the necessary steps to hedge against
inflation today and protect your
hard-earned money get your free info kit
by texting wall to
9898-98 now
so now it's my turn and I expected that
something like this might happen it had
to had to happen I've been successful in
fighting against the left's agenda
especially the trans agenda and
especially recently those who support
the sexual mutilation of children know
full well that I am a threat to them
because we're winning and they're losing
and they know that too and they can't
engage with our with our arguments they
can't uh oppose us on the battlefield of
ideas so instead they look for another
way and now they're convinced they found
their kill shot against Me by using the
same method they always use which is
digging up ancient history doing the
internet equivalent of rummaging through
garbage cans to find things that were
done and said years ago which can be
used to defame and they hope silence me
today
so yes my my PR team over at Media
Matters apparently wasn't satisfied to
promote just my current show and all the
work they do there so they decided to go
back 15 years to my time as a rock radio
host on an obscure station in uh
Delaware which is also an obscure State
and they spent it would seem many
tedious hours listening to segments and
bits from my time as a shock jock in my
early 20s it could not have been easy to
sit through I I commend their
persistence at least
and now they've compiled their findings
into an expose that promises to reveal
my quote sordid pest
honestly I I never thought of myself as
having assorted past I figured my life
was far too boring and sort of uh banal
and normal for that
but it turns out that I'm a more
interesting person than I had previously
thought
so as for the vultures and Media Matters
and the leftists who've picked up this
hit piece and run with it they are not
very interesting they are doing what
they always do they're as pathetic and
desperate as I've always known them to
be
the left they're not interested in
investigating children's hospitals that
literally castrate and butcher children
in fact such investigations I've been
told are an act of terrorism
but they will take the time to scour the
internet for evidence that I made
offensive remarks when I was 23 years
old
that in their minds is far more relevant
to the public it's a matter of uh of
Greater National urgency they think
so with that in mind
let's talk now if this is what they want
to talk about for a few moments about
the deep dark secrets of my past these
skeletons that have been hiding in my
closet waiting to be discovered by
Intrepid reporters and Media Matters I
will tell you the whole ghastly story
even the parts that Media Matters didn't
include
I'll tell you the whole story
so when I was 20 years old I moved into
a one-bedroom apartment in a small town
in Delaware and started working at a
rock station with a staggering audience
that easily reached into the
hundreds I think
those are my humble beginnings or or
maybe the dark and Sinister origins of
the world's most notorious terrorists
depending on who you listen to
so I worked at the station until I was
25 for a couple of years during that
period I hosted a Morning Show
where we often did flout the rules of
political correctness as was the custom
on morning radio at the time
in their headpiece Media Matters
presents evidence
that I used racially insensitive humor
that I told inappropriate jokes
that I engaged in lots of offensive
activities
all of that
of course is true they also accuse me of
physically abusing our radio interns
by tasing one of them as a joke
that's also true and I submit still
funny
In fairness I got tased too in fact I
invented a game back in those days
called taser trivia where as the name
suggests you are asked trivia questions
and if you get it wrong you get taste
Media Matters didn't post that video but
but they should have because it's quite
shocking literally and figuratively so
I'll post it for you now here it is
category will be science and nature okay
and three question
what astrological chart takes its name
from a Greek word meaning circle of
little animals oh no no hold on all
right
astrological chart that takes its name
from what
Circle
this again
this sucks guys getting the taser out
circle of little animals circle of
little animals
um
um uh it uh
just answer it uh the answer is uh uh
the uh the chart of um
of uh
the chart of magnesia
oh God
now if I should be canceled for anything
uh it for it should be for for being
such a such a pansy in that video like
that was embarrassing actually
get it together I mean it does hurt to
get to get tased and for some reason we
decided to add the blindfolds into it as
well to just make it more because you
never know when the tase is coming
our biggest mistake was that we used
Trivial Pursuit questions we use like
old school Trivial Pursuit as the
questions for dead taser trivia I don't
think anyone got the answer right so we
just got taste 50 times
anyway that's the sort of content that
you missed out on if you didn't live in
Southern Delaware in the early 2000s but
there's more Media Matters reveals that
I once challenged the intern to lick the
inside of a dumpster
which again is true but the part they
leave out is that afterwards we called a
doctor on the air to find out what sort
of diseases he might have picked up from
the stunt
and from what I recall the answer was uh
many
also again as Media Matters exposes like
any other hacky Morning Show at the time
we did prank calls and some of the prank
calls were offensive by current
standards sometimes on a call I would
imitate a black man on one occasion I
attempted to portray a man with split
personalities one of whom was black and
the other white it was very high concept
sort of work and it worked better on
paper than it did in execution I could
tell you but not all of our prank calls
were racially charged only most of them
were
we did one where I called a hotel
pretending to be
pretending to be a wizard who had left
his magical sword in his room
it was I think without question the
nerdiest prank call anyone has ever made
and it deserves to be recognized
as such in the Guinness Book of World
Records I submit but Media Matters
didn't include that video in their
expose maybe they can find room for it
in the follow-up that I'm sure is coming
uh yet it wasn't all fun and games Media
Matters reports that I made politically
inflammatory statements including at a
tea party rally where I got into an
argument
with a guy in the audience while I was
on the stage and it ended with me
calling him and quote old fart
that's the kind of devastating insult I
could throw around before I became one
myself
but my political extremism wasn't
confined to yelling at people at uh tea
party rallies
one thing Media Matters doesn't mention
perhaps doesn't know but now they will
is that I ran for mayor of my town at
that time and and I lost by a vote of if
I remember correctly 450 to 26.
the campaign ultimately floundered
because I never uh campaigned and also I
had no platform of any kind and I mainly
just entered the race because I thought
it would be funny and it was and also I
really wanted to try my hand at making a
corny campaign ad where I say absolutely
nothing of substance and that at the end
of the day was really the only reason I
ran was just so that I could
do this here it is
[Applause]
cut off we need to remove the alternator
and slip past the water pump let me get
that half inch socket
thanks
all right let's give it a shot here
oh hey how's it going
friend crank here got himself stranded
again
car broken down you know something
just strikes me I think georgetown's a
little broken down too don't you
but don't worry sometimes you just need
a friend to come by and help you out of
a jam and that's all I'm going to do as
mayor of Georgetown but to fix a car
just like to fix a broken City you need
a few things
first of all the right tools a wrench
well works perfect for a car but not for
a city to fix a city what you need is
some integrity
a little bit of honesty how about some
character
and then there was that LSD we talked
about earlier loyalty strength and
devotion
I truly can't believe I only got 26
votes but it doesn't end there other
leftists have joined the hunt digging up
their own evidence and this is when the
pilot pylon starts happening right one
of them starts it and says look at all
these terrible things and then everyone
else says I'm gonna find more terrible
things and they did they found more
terrible thing things one now viral
video that's making the rounds online
shows me and my co-host burning a book
over a charcoal grill
and then we then dance around the flames
and make whooping noises like Indians
that's all real you see that video it's
100 real we really did that but the back
story is that we had the author of that
book whose name I forget on the show and
he annoyed us for reasons that I also
forget so we said we were gonna burn his
book in reprisal and we did
and again it was funny
though in hindsight probably not the
best thing to do in the middle of a
political campaign
but the left is not satisfied so merely
accuse me of racism terrorism political
extremism workplace violence
but also absurdly claiming that I
advocated child Brides
and for that bit of defamation they are
using another segment from over a decade
ago where we discussed the issue of teen
pregnancy
and I pointed out that in the past teen
pregnancy wasn't considered a problem
because people got married younger I was
attempting to highlight in an admittedly
awkward and rambling way in my early 20s
riffing off the top of my head during a
rock Morning Show to an audience of
almost no one at the time the fact that
unwed pregnancy is a core problem that
plagues our society and it's still a
problem even when the unwed pregnant
person is an adult so no matter the age
I argued at the time pregnancy has
become a crisis when they happen outside
of marriage without a stable family
structure in place to care for the child
this was again not an issue in earlier
times because people got married young
and stayed married
it's not the way our society is today
though of course
at its core it's a rather
uncontroversial historical observation
but the left has latched on to this
point from years ago and tried to use it
to flip the groomer label around on me
accusing me of quote promoting teen
pregnancy and even child rape as some of
the
libelist statements would have it this
is a defamatory lie they know it's a lie
and it shows how desperate they are
they've chosen the most toxic smears
available because smears are all they
have
now in summary my enemies have thrown
every last thing they can at me the
whole kitchen sink and a few of the
appliances to go along with it I'm not
the first person to get this treatment
obviously I certainly won't be the last
their objective is nothing less than the
wholesale destruction of my life in my
career that's what they're going for
that's the price they expect me to pay
for opposing them effectively they hope
to force me to submit and apologize at
which point of course as it goes they'll
shoo me away with my tail between my
legs out of public view out of the Arena
off Into Obscurity
This Is My Punishment you know the life
sentence they expect me to serve for
trying to stop them from abusing and
butchering children
and it's not just me thereafter you know
they want to send a message to everybody
else they want to send a message to you
that if you stand up against them this
is what happens
they want to make me into another head
on a spike one of many
they put out on the edge of town a
warning to anyone else who might think
about
disobeying their rules
so here's my official answer for the
record
um
kiss my ass
I do not apologize
in fact by All rights you sick freaks
should be the ones apologizing to me
for lying and defaming me and doing it
all because I'm trying to prevent you
from sexually mutilating children
you damned monsters
you child abusing Psychopaths
I wouldn't apologize to you soulless
parasites if I had a gun to my head
instead I'd rather just tell you all to
piss off
I apologize for nothing I concede
nothing
I Will Never Surrender even a single
inch of ground to a pitchfork mob of
degenerate morons
you know the secret they never say out
loud is that nobody is truly canceled
unless they consent to it and they
willingly play their assigned roles
well I do not consent
and I'm not going to play the game
I'm not going anywhere
I am more motivated than ever to oppose
you
and to fight against everything you
stand for
because I hate everything you stand for
and I hate it more with each passing day
so you can try to humiliate me you could
try to ruin my reputation you can accuse
me of all of the most heinous crimes
that you can invent in your tiny
feverish little brains
but I am not going anywhere
staying in a fight never leaving
I promise you that
also for the record I will always
maintain that tasers are a wonderful
source of Comedy
that's not going to change either
now let's get to our five headlines
you know the left is losing their faith
but uh we're not and a core part of that
faith is prayer I talk a lot about
stressful things all day and you might
feel a little overwhelmed with where the
country is going but I've got good news
Hollow can help you find some peace and
hope rooted not in the government or its
institutions but in God hallow has over
5 000 audio guided prayers meditations
and peaceful Christian music including
the rosary with Bishop Baron and Mark
Wahlberg the uh they've got Bible
bedtime stories with Jonathan Jonathan
Rooney and many more as well hello helps
you build and a daily routine and a
habit of prayer helps me to pray to
meditate and sleep better it's a huge
part of my daily routine and it should
be for you too get an exclusive
three-month trial of hallow at hello.com
Matt Walsh that's hallow.com Matt Walsh
reclaim your piece in this crazy world
download hello today
you know the one other thing to note
here before we move on is that uh this
is a problem that the left is going to
have
is that I am uncancelable I mean they
literally can't do it
you cannot cancel me it is impossible
and uh one of the reasons that it's
impossible is as I said I don't consent
to it I'm not going to go along with it
and you always need the person to go
along with it and the other reason is
that I work for the daily wire
um who I have their full support and
their full backing and that hasn't
changed never is going to change
um that's one of the great things about
the daily wire is that daily wire also
does not consent to taking part in
cancel campaigns especially ones that
are so transparently devised to distract
from all of the the victories that we're
achieving uh which is another reason why
you know uh if you do support a daily
wire
I thank you for that and if you don't if
you're not a member yet you should
really think about uh joining joining
the team
speaking of things that we're fighting
against I've had this on the docket for
several days and I haven't gotten to it
yet so uh now seems like a good time to
get to it we'll begin the five headlines
with it this is from Vox and uh the
headline is What's So Scary About a
transgender transgender child
and then the subheading stop worrying
about what happens if we let kids
transition
worry about what happens if we don't
so this is the this is of course how the
narrative works is that
first we're told I mean for for months
and months and months we've been told
that they're not transitioning children
what are you talking about that's crazy
that's not happening that's
misinformation you're making that up and
now they're saying uh what do you mean
what's what's the big deal with threat
in fact we have to transition them
because it's uh it's if we don't the
scary thing is if we don't transition
them
so we it's it's that's not happening
that would never happen also it is
happening and it must happen and you're
a terrible person if you don't want it
to happen so they are asserting all of
those things at the same exact time
simultaneously
uh reading a little bit from the article
says Lily Osler who is uh who is
disclosure a friend in parentheses
perfectly captures the terror of puberty
for Trans kids in a Waco Tribune Herald
piece exploring Texas's ongoing
Crackdown on trans youth
now quoting it says puberty blockers are
reversible but the puberty that
transgender kids would go through
without them isn't puberty writes itself
into our bones without blockers and at
an appropriate age hormones it forces
transgender girls who are girls like any
other to grow facial hair and Broad
angular features and forces transgender
boys to grow breasts and wide hips
you have to you have to appreciate that
sentence there it forces transgender
girls who are girls like any other to
grow facial hair and Broad angular
features well uh that would seem to
indicate that they're not girls like any
other I mean if they're growing full-on
beards and you know they and and and
if they're growing uh the features of a
of a boy then it would seems a pretty
good indication that they're not girls
like any other
um
and what forces are they say it forces
it forces so what do we
what are we talking about here we're
talking about nature we're talking about
it's it is so incoherent to talk about
puberty this way it's incoherent to talk
about the the development of the human
body in this way it's like if I said
um you know I I am forced to be six foot
one
it's really like six and foot three
quarters but we'll call six of one I am
forced to be six foot one
now on on some level
that's true I guess I mean I I don't I
don't have a choice in the matter I
don't decide what my height is
but it's such an odd and misleading way
of putting it isn't it intentionally
misleading
because Force sounds like there's some
existential you know force that there's
like another there's some other Force
out there some someone who's doing this
to you who's making you like someone
made me be
six foot one give or take
when that is just that's just nature
that's just that's simply what I am
um
continues its effects can only be
reversed by very expensive and difficult
to access surgeries of adulthood and
even then only partially
uh continuing it says quote this is not
experimental care this is care that's
been around in a very formal fashion for
over 50 years said Michelle forsier a
professor at Browns University Medical
School and co-editor of pediatric gender
identity we know that there are studies
that demonstrate efficacy and safety
um it's also interesting that Michelle
forsier we read an article I figured
which article was we read an article
last week where she she popped up and
she was featured in the article so uh
she obviously isn't what is a woman we
talked to her what is a woman and now
I'm very loath to say to say the
sentence about to say but to her credits
maybe she is at least willing to talk
about this
sort of willing I mean she well she
threatened to get up and leave the room
multiple times through our during our
conversation but she did sit there
um she's at least willing to defend sort
of
gender ideology
but it just goes to show that there are
so few willing to publicly defend it
there's so few who are willing to
publicly defend it even
to sympathetic
people even in a in a sympathetic
context like talking to Vox
there are so few who are willing to do
it because they know that they're but
they at some level they know their
position is indefensible so there's a
there's a relatively small even though
this ideology has gripped hold of our
whole society there's a relatively small
uh circle of people who they have to
pull from
anytime they want to write an article
promoting this stuff there's only a few
people they can that are available
because only a few people are willing to
actually defend this stuff
um continues the recent hyper focus on
trans youth is largely a media invention
says Jules uh Jill Peterson a history
professor at Johns Hopkins University
trans people and trans youth were never
really objects of the media until
recently I really don't think most
people ever encountered the idea that
they shared the world with trans youth
until the last 10 years
well that I actually agree with
yeah I I know this is not how they mean
it but quote trans youth yeah that is an
invention of the media and not just the
media
I mean Academia medical industry uh lots
of other institutions but largely the
media this is this is and you're right
it's it's absolutely correct that up
until 10 years ago nobody was really
talking about trans kids
and we're talking about it now uh
because of the media
but that's because the trans kids didn't
exist
prior to about 10 years ago
there were almost none at all there are
almost no kids who would identify as
trans 10 years ago before that
now there are a whole bunch
thanks to the media and social media and
all these other institutions
um
it says the recency of the
hypervisibility powers the notion that
trans Healthcare is somehow still
experimental abstracting something that
is fraught with life and death Stakes
for a trans person the changes dictate
by the body uh that they were born into
prove incredibly painful destabilizing
or even life-threatening
Jack turbin so I told you they're always
pulling from the same pool of people and
Jack turb is another guy that that uh
that always pops up in these articles
because there are only a few that are
willing to talk about it the risks of
withholding gender affirming care he
says vary from Patient to Patient but
often involve things like worsening
anxiety depression and suicidality
recent legislation to take affirming
Medical Care as an option away across
the board is extremely dangerous and
will lead to bad outcomes a 2022 study
published in the Canadian Medical
Association Journal found that trans
teens were 7.6 times more likely to
attempt suicide than their CIS peers
and I mean that's that's pretty much the
article it goes on much longer than that
but uh and yet again you know that part
is also true that uh
the suicidality among trans-identified
people is I mean it's at least 7.6 Times
Higher I've I've you know there are some
statistics that would say
you know 10 times higher and more
um the attempted suicide rate I think is
like 40 or something around there it's
just it's these are staggering numbers
but what they
what what
they don't tell you
is they don't tell you two things
first of all they don't tell you that it
is the
the disconnect that a person has you
know the fact that they have delusions
about themselves the fact that they're
not able to accept themselves for who
they are we talk about self-acceptance
yesterday true self-acceptance accepting
yourself for who you really are if
you're not able to do that if you're
having trouble doing that then yeah
that's going to lead to despair that's
going to lead to hopelessness and uh in
the most tragic scenarios at least
suicide
so what do you do about that well you
help someone to accept themselves you
help them to understand
who they actually are and that it's good
to be who they are and there's nothing
wrong with it and they should embrace it
and yes there are there are many
different ways to be who you are
so if you're a boy that doesn't mean
that every boy has to wear exactly the
same thing like they're all walking
around in uniforms all the time oh they
all have to have exactly the same
Hobbies or exactly the same temperaments
and personalities there are many
different ways to to be yourself but you
are yourself and you can't change that
the other thing they don't tell you is
that yes the suicide rate is high but
are their studies proving that this
gender affirming care reduces
uh the suicide rate and the answer is no
they'll tell you that there are but the
answer in fact is no and the only
long-term incredible study on this has
shown that in fact suicide rate is
highest after transition than before
all right Joe Biden went down to Florida
to get in the way during the cleanup
efforts and he also said this
we're in a situation where the Colorado
River looks more like a stream there's a
lot going on
and I think the one thing this has
finally ended is a discussion about
whether or not there's climate change we
should do something about it but folks I
also want to uh Jill and I have had you
all in our prayers
so the the hurricane ends the discussion
about climate change
why does it do that exactly
I'm trying to I'm
trying to draw the figure out the
connection and I don't see it so so why
would this particular hurricane
end the discussion about climate change
now does it end the discussion about
whether there is climate change
for the millionth time
we can't really end that discussion
because there never was a discussion
about that no one is debating that
nobody denies that the the climates
change the climate is in the constant
state of flux that's changing all the
time it changes every second of every
day
um in fact everything you know that
that's everything in life that's one of
the
uh sometimes Bittersweet sometimes
tragic but but you know it's just it's a
reality of life that everything changes
all the time if you
if you know if I were to get up and
leave this room and then I come back to
it five seconds later nothing in this
room is exactly the same as it was
before I left because on some even at
even maybe at a level that I can't see
at a microscopic level things are
changing and moving around all the time
right
um and then when you when you expand
that out to the macro
that is uh certainly even more the case
and something like the climate which is
by its nature volatile
Ever Changing ever developing
so
it doesn't end that conversation because
there never was any conversation
but I think I think what he really means
is that it ends the conversation it ends
the debate about
um
the degree to which human beings
contribute to climate change
and he also thinks it ends the debate
about uh you know whether or not we
should put all these various policies
the Democrats support in place to combat
climate change that's what he really
means
and as far as that goes uh I'm not sure
does he think this is the first
hurricane that's ever happened why would
this hurricane end the conversation but
not the hurricane before that or that or
that or not why not the next one
because the other thing about the
climate is that along with changing all
the time as I said it's volatile
and in a constant state of flux
and that means that that it's constantly
creating
um catastrophic weather events all the
time including hurricanes
and now this happened for literally
billions of years
all right it's from daily wire it says
months after an Ohio school high school
hosted a drag event featuring multiple
performers who encourage students to
explore their gender identities
one Mother wearing the same outfit as
one of the performers blasted school
board members over their alleged failure
to address parental concerns
so she came to the school board meeting
wearing one of the outfits
that that a drag performer at the school
had worn and she was doing that to make
a point
as revealed by a previous report from
the daily wire and videos captured by
Libs of tick tock the gay straight
Alliance Club at n Kenny High School
invited drag queen performers in May for
their end-of-year meeting without
obtaining permission from administrators
one of the drag queens donned a
one-shouldered uh black leotard and long
black boots before performing a
provocative dance for students Kimberly
reichs the founder of Parental the
parental rights group Iowa Mama bears
noted during public comments at a Monday
school board meeting that officials have
neglected to provide the results of
their investigation halfway through her
marks the mother of seven removed her
sweatpants and her jacket to reveal the
same outfit that the drag queen had been
wearing
she says in the in the clip she says
does this outfit make your head turn
does this outfit seem appropriate for
anybody uh here to see this is what the
man dressed like in front of your kids
so if this makes your head spin if this
pisses you off in any way shape or form
it should because I'm embarrassed to
stand here in the outfit that I'm in
today but I have to put a point to prove
that this outfit should not ever be
accepted in our schools anywhere
and that is a a
I mean a pretty brilliant maneuver on
her part
and it really does I think send a
message it makes the point
that
you know the absurdity just the abject
absurdity of all of this is that
you know
it is now considered
appropriate
for men to wear women's outfits
certain types of women out women's
outfits in context when it would not be
considered appropriate even for a woman
to wear them
I think this is a just a a perfect way
to prove that point
yeah she looks ridiculous wearing that
outfit at a school function it's just
not an appropriate outfit
it's not even appropriate for women and
if it's not appropriate for women it
would be it's not that it's less
appropriate for me to be even more
inappropriate for for men
obviously
yeah I point this out all the time with
uh with with the the drag shows where
they invite kids to it
this is what's insane about it one of
the many things that's insane about it
that if you were to take all those men
and keep everything the same
outfits are the same
performances are the same
the you know given tips the kids running
up there with money cash tips to give to
the performers keep all that the same
but instead make them women
if that was the case then everyone would
probably agree that this is not
appropriate for kids
because if they're actual women rather
than men dressed up like women it
becomes what it is which is a burlesque
performance
drag is is male burlesque it is a male
burlesque performance
now you can feel however you feel about
burlesque performances and if you're an
adult and you're in Las Vegas and you
want to go to a to something like that
you can
but would anyone really think that it's
appropriate to bring a kid to a to a
burlesque
performance much less to have one at a
school
and anyone who suggested that you would
say well why why do you want this in the
school what's the point of all the
things of all the ways that we could use
the time you want to bring someone in
and we want to use the auditorium and we
could do something educational you want
to have a burlesque uh we we would
totally reject that for women but you
you
switch them out and make them men and
it's supposed to be now suddenly
acceptable
uh all right moving on this is from
the daily wire says the satanic temple
filed lawsuits in federal court against
Idaho and Indiana last month over near
total abortion bans in both States
citing a list of accusations surrounding
religious rights uh blocking a women's
right to engage in these satanic
abortion ritual
in the wake of the U.S Supreme Court
overturning Roe v Wade with the
opposition James McNaughton who's an
attorney representing the satanic temple
told axios that the historic reversal
that returned abortion access to the
States has quote woken a sleeping giant
among women politically and have stirred
up a hornet's nest of legal issues
added quote Gorsuch you want a national
debate on abortion congratulations you
have one
now
yeah we've we've seen a lot of headlines
about this and and the the satanic
temple has been very involved they were
very upset uh about abortion so-called
abortion rights being taken away in some
states
even though that's happening in states
where I'm guessing there are very few
you know professing satanists
but even so they're very upset about it
and so the satanic temple they want to
position themselves at the Forefront of
this conversation they want to make
themselves a leader leaders of the in
the fight for quote-unquote abortion
rights and I think that's great I think
it's just fantastic
um I I hope they continue in these
efforts I really do
and uh I I also agree that they should
be at the lead they should be in the
Forefront they should be at the head of
the parade
because it is exactly right that
abortion is a Satanic ritual
so the more the satanists outright
profess Satan and satanists the more
they're involved uh the more it puts
this
issue in the correct framing
puts it in its proper place
that abortion is a Satanic ritual
and why is this Satanic ritual you know
why why do they consider it sacred well
you can ask them that and they'll tell
you they're pretty open about it and the
reason is that's um
you know the people that profess
themselves to be saying this
most of them don't think of themselves
as literally worshiping the devil
um in fact they would reject that the
devil even exists and yet they call and
yet they've named themselves after him
well why is that because
rather than
openly worshiping the devil they are
doing their modeling themselves after
Satan they are doing what Satan does so
instead of wwjd it's wwsd for them and
uh Satan worshiped him himself
I was cast out of heaven right as
scripture tells us so uh that's what
satanists do it is Satanism is the
worship of the self it's not really the
worship of Satan it's the worship of
it's the worship of what Satan worship
which is the self
and when it comes to worshiping the self
you know if you have made the self into
your God and that and that's your
religion
then yeah abortion for them becomes this
sacred Sacrament this Unholy sacrament
because you are sacrificing it is a
blood sacrifice
to the self
you're sacrificing your own children
for yourself so that yourself can be you
know so that you can
have comfort and luxury and not be
inconvenienced and everything else
it's really the ultimate statement
it's it if you can think of no state of
a of a of a statement
there's no more profound and dramatic
way to make the statement that I care
about myself above anything and
everything in the universe
they the ultimate declaration
is by
killing your own child
you're saying I don't even I I put
myself even above my own child
all right this is from Fox News it says
the animal rights activist who ran onto
the field with a pink smoke bomb at
Levi's Stadium in Santa Clara California
on Monday night during a game between
the Los Angeles Rams and San Francisco
49ers has filed a police report for
assault
by Rams players who tackled him to end
his demonstration before I read this any
further we should probably watch that
moment
purely for educational purposes
um
okay who put up because there's the guy
he's not nude at least usually these
streakers are and then oh he gets he
gets taken out see that is well let's go
back and look that again yeah that's a
form form tackle there's no helmet to
helmet there
um he's leaning so he's leaning he's
he's leading with his shoulder
and it's really it's a shoulder against
shoulder tackle that is well within the
rules of of the NFL
and if you step onto the NFL field if
you step onto the football field well
now you are it's what matters are are
the rules of football
yeah in a normal circumstance if you're
just taking a jog down the street and
someone runs up and tackles you then
that's assault
but on a football field
you know
in between the sidelines
the rules are different
um a person close to Alex Taylor the man
who was taken down by Ram's linebacker
Bobby Wagner and defensive end uh
takaris McKinley during this
demonstration
told Fox News that he's considering his
options including legal action against
the players involved and the NFL
direct action everywhere is the
organization took responsibility for the
demonstration by Taylor and Allison
Flutie who was apprehended before
running on the field Taylor was able to
avoid Levi's Stadium security before
Wagner McKinley stepped in and put an
end to the demonstration
and now he's okay so now he's thinking
about suing or filing charges because he
was assaulted
um
and Wagner was asked about this and he
said that uh he doesn't really want to
talk about it anymore he's already
addressed it but he also says that
actions have consequences
he says there's consequences for your
actions
which I think just about summarizes it
this is probably the ultimate example of
uh F around and find out as the kids
would say
let's get to the comment section
[Music]
[Music]
well I've been debating telling this
story
um
because it's somewhat embarrassing but
it's also funny
and at this point
what difference does it make so here's
another story for my sordid past
another skeleton buried deeply in my
closet
secret that I've kept hidden for so long
in this case I've kept it hidden for
about four days to be precise
so this past Saturday uh I went with my
wife and some other members of The Daily
wire crew
Michael Brett Cooper the god king Jeremy
boring other members of the executive
team
we went to the Gary Sinise Foundation
fundraising banquet for veterans at the
uh the Gaylord here in Nashville it's
very nice event very Swanky uh sort of
event where I feel horribly out of place
there were lots of famous people Milling
around Renee Zellweger was there it was
emceed by Kelsey Grammer and Patricia
Heaton Mark Wahlberg made a surprise uh
appearance by video and it may sound
like I'm only telling you this story so
I can brag about this fancy dinner but
you'll soon see that that is not the
case that's not the point
so early on in the night before the main
course was served they're doing a lot of
there's a lot of introductions
formalities ceremonial type stuff which
is normal for an event like this and
there are lots of reasons to stand and
so we're getting our cardio in you know
standing doing standing ovations and so
on we stood for the anthem we stood for
various other things about 20 minutes
into this I get a little distracted they
come by they're picking up the salad
plates it's making clanking noises like
people are just chatting going on
I'm distracted I'm only half listening
to what's being said up on the stage
and what I hear I hear that the person
say something something please rise
something something
so I instinctively thought that you know
we were Rising maybe to for the prayer
before the meal or the pledge or
something like that so uh so I stand
because she said please rise and we've
been we've already been standing a lot
so I just I stood
and after I stand I look around and I
realize that not everyone is standing in
fact only about a third of the room is
standing
but at this point I'm already committed
I can't sit back down I'm In Too Deep
right and at first I thought well hey
you know maybe we're the more patriotic
ones maybe we're you know we're standing
to for you know whatever it is we're
standing for maybe it's because we're
the more patriotic ones but then to my
horror the rest of the audience begins
to applaud us who are standing
and now I'm panicking in my head because
I'm thinking
um all right
I stood to be applauded for something I
don't know what
uh did they ask for podcasters to stand
up and be recognized let's hope it's
that it seems unlikely
then I sit back down and Knowles who was
just beaming with Glee at this point
turns to me and goes
thank you for your service
and then I realized that they asked
military members to stand
and I stood
but I didn't serve in the military
so I stole Valor I am guilty of Stolen
Valor accidentally but here's the worst
part this is why I really want to bring
this up I was at a table
with my friends my colleagues my wife my
own wife and none of them told me to sit
down none of them tugged on my jacket
and said hey sit down idiot it's not you
instead apparently they were just like
giggling like school girls enjoying my
humiliation
um allowing me to accidentally steal
Valor for 35 seconds
this is all really their fault is what I
guess what I'm trying to say
um and then for the rest of the night
every time there was a uh another
occasion to stand my wife would lean in
and say you can stand for this
and then at one point Jeremy comes over
from another table and he says oh so I
was just over there Googling did Matt
Walsh serve in the military
everyone had a good laugh over that
was very much the butt of the joke the
entire evening and then I made the
mistake of telling Sean my producer
about this on Monday and later that
afternoon we're boarding a plane and
they call for boarding group one and I
walk by and Sean says are you boarding
for first class or because you're in the
military
so these are the jokes that I
have invited so
what's the what's the real lesson that's
you know I guess it's like
don't don't just stand because everybody
else is
I guess no that puts the blame back on
me I was trying to shift it and I'm
shifting it back over to the people that
are there with me all right Smith says
imagine being in the hotel room next to
the Sweet Daddy and hearing him do the
podcast through the walls I actually
think about that uh every single time
we're at a hotel room doing the podcast
because you know hotel room walls are
pretty thin and so yeah there is at
every single hotel we stop at there's
there's at least one person who against
their will is forced to experience uh
the Matt wall Show podcast
and if they were forced to experience
this one in particular without context
they are going to be very confused
Teriyaki says your first showing of what
is a woman had more in attendance than
Bros had in over 3000 theaters uh that
yeah that's sort of true like I would
like to say that so we've done okay well
we had we had the screening at uh at the
Catholic University
before that our our one real sort of
screening in a movie theater happened in
uh Franklin Tennessee just south of
Nashville and we had I think we sold the
place out with like 350 people
and I did do the math on it and I think
Bros would have averaged 150 per
screening so we doubled them
so we got that going at least
um
and Curtis says Matt's message about
self-hatred resonates with my experience
with men who transitioned to women while
I was working in mental health they were
unhappy with how they were they were
convinced that getting surgery and
hormones would make them happy and when
it didn't they were filled with rage and
depression back then it was harder to
transition there was a requirement for
psychiatric evaluation with that now
gone I'm sure it is much worse
um yeah you know in a lot of ways this
this you know thinking that you can
transition and make yourself happy it is
uh it's it's the kind of mistake
and misunderstanding that that everybody
makes oftentimes in much less dramatic
and permanent ways
but it's it's it's a kind of common
human misconception that if you're very
unhappy
um you could just change some external
thing and that'll fix it
so you'll hear someone's like they're
unhappy so they're just gonna like move
to another town or you know they're just
like they they look for these external
things that they can change
um thinking that's going to make them
happy uh but but it very rarely works
because that happiness is it's it's come
it's internal right a lot of that is is
emanating from within it's coming from
within it's not from without
and so you can change the external but
it's not going to change what's going on
inside and again that's so the gender
transition is just the most horrific
permanent dramatic example of that kind
of misconception where in this case
someone's saying I'm going to change all
of these external
aspects of my body
and hope that that doesn't but it still
doesn't because the problem again is
internal it's inside you
you know this Monday we will celebrate
one of my personal favorite holidays and
the left's least favorite Columbus Day
and while many woke companies will
ignore or attempt to Rebrand this
holiday Jeremy's razors will honor it
with an historic estate sale from now uh
through October 12th you can purchase a
Founder series shave kit for 40 off plus
free shipping that's a one percent
discount for each of the 40 Christopher
Columbus statues that have been removed
or destroyed in this country by
illiterate buffoons it's time to stand
up and celebrate history in defiance of
those who wish to cancel it and stop
giving your money to woke razor
companies that hate you give it to
Jeremy instead navigate your way to
jeremy'srazors.com and enjoy a sale for
the ages now let's get to our daily
cancellation
foreign
cancellation we turn to the contentious
subject of gender reveals of course a
gender reveal is the I believe quite
modern tradition of an expecting couple
announcing the baby's sex through some
elaborate bit of pageantry people
sometimes go to exorbitant lengths to
reveal their baby's gender unfortunately
these methods tend to involve
pyrotechnics and fireworks and over the
last few years many thousands of
innocent lives have been lost due to
gender reveal mishaps I believe the
current estimate is that one out of
every five people in the country will
die from a gender reveal related
accident I think that's an actual
statistic that I just made up the death
toll has had the effect of making gender
reveals slightly less popular over time
and certainly more controversial now
some argue that revealing the gender is
worth any price Humanity must pay for it
others argue that they would prefer not
to have their home and family
incinerated because somebody wanted to
set off fireworks that spell the words
it's a boy in the sky so there's
something to be said I think for both
perspectives uh both are valid
but all of this has given rise to a new
favorite American Pastime
um so on one hand there is the gender
reveal and on the other there is the
increasingly popular tradition of
complaining about gender reveals this
will become a war of attrition once the
anti-gender reveal factions start using
fireworks to spell out their arguments
at that point it won't be long until the
whole world is aflame we inch closer to
that apocalyptic reality every day
especially the more we hear stories like
this this is from Yahoo news a gender
reveal party in Brazil last month
sparked an investigation after a local
waterfall was dyed blue during a couple
celebration according to authorities
um last month Mato grosso's environment
Protection Agency said the 59-foot
waterfall known as
not even attempt that yes I will caco
era
came up hey caco era came a pay
cacoera kimape
anyway was dyed blue by a family member
of the expectant couple according to
Washington Post according to SEMA the
waterfall feeds into a river that serves
as a water source for uh another thing
that I won't pronounce which has been
experiencing droughts in recent years
the paper reports the original video
which has since been deleted off
Instagram showed the moment the
waterfall turned blue to indicate the
couple are expecting a boy according to
the independent clips that have been
shared online also show the party's
balloon decorations powder cannons and
shearing guests the video sparked
backlash with many social media users
criticizing the use of the dyed
waterfall at the Gathering
first of all aren't waterfalls already
kind of blue in the first place
so it seems unnecessary
now yes it does it does it it may seem
gratuitous to contaminate a whole water
supply in order to tell the world you're
having a boy
um we have never elected in our family
that sort of strategy with any of our
children personally for us it's always
it's always seemed easier to tell people
the sex of the child
by well just telling them the sex of the
child uh we just use our vocal cords to
express ourselves in that regard and
that's why I'm sympathetic to the
criticisms of gender reveals in fact I
believe that in the past I have actually
canceled gender reveals during this very
segment for the reasons that have
already been outlined
but I've had a change of heart
um I don't think I've ever done anything
like this before
but uh today you know today's uh is a a
day of first in so many ways today I am
canceling my cancellation it is not
gender reveals that are canceled I've
decided
but the critics of gender reveals
except me and the reason is simple
we live in a culture where it is now
actually I think it is now actually
worthwhile to celebrate and acknowledge
a child's gender before birth
there is value now in making special
note of the fact that the child has a
gender that the gender is knowable and
it is known
every gender reveal
signifies a child who will be born with
an identity rather than an identity
crisis
as this may not be the explicit
intention of the people who engage in
this practice but in effect it is a
celebration of biological truth it flies
directly in the face of the Absurd
modern notion that a baby's gender can't
be determined at all and we have to wait
for him to decide for himself
you must also you might also say that
the gender reveal is a celebration of
the humanity of the child in utero it's
a very pro-life tradition You could
argue according to the left the baby in
the womb has no personhood at all at a
loan agenda he is a nondescript
ambiguous clump of organic matter
and then he's born
and through his passage to the birth
canal somehow in he is imbued magically
with with the Breath of Life they say
but he's still ambiguous
um he's neither male nor female he is
this sexless being stuck in limbo
until one day he picks up a Barbie doll
and and that's what makes him a girl
so this is how the left imagines that
gender is determined and it's why they
have argued Demi Lovato said this
recently that um gender reveal parties
are transphobic
forget contaminating the water supply or
burning down a thousand acres of forest
what they really hate about the gender
reveal is that it reveals the gender
it tells the secret that they would
rather keep hidden away even from the
child himself it asserts an objective
reality
and there is nothing the left hates more
than that
and that ultimately is why I must
finally come to the defense
even if nobody else will of the gender
reveal
and say to its distractor detractors
with whom I used to align myself
you are canceled
now that'll do it for us today as we
move over to the members block of the
show hope to talk to you uh then if not
talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]